I hit the button the button let me know
wait I see when I saw her sad I see
starting I see starting and I kidding I
see any good outside I didn't even get
in there yet up in time love y'all
alright
and we Oh laughs welcome to the iron
Lords podcast and the Lords of gaming
dotnet episode number 143 it's another
glorious Sunday we're back at the round
table of the Lord's Day I'm very excited
about our special guests and we've got
80s retro discussion PS 5 faster than
the Xbox series ex film Spencer in Japan
and Nintendo refunds to discuss so we
gotta get right into it I want to
introduce a lord whose content is not
only a beacon of positivity positivity
on the YouTube platform but whose
passion for the days of our youth
resonates in every detail video at every
nostalgic sound he reproduces
introducing the creator and host of the
micro mercy youtube channel toy guys
talking podcasts and the Lord of all 80s
nostalgia the GI Joe and transformers
King and also the leader of the nerd
mistake movement live from Canada and
kind enough to make his debut into the
realm of the Lords mahmud Lord Michael
mercy how you doing sir
wow what an intro thank you so much holy
smokes you forgot world heavyweight yoga
oh yeah listen man you are a lord at
what you do it is only right we show you
the proper respect here at the round
table bad how have you been doing what
you've been playing what you've been
work it what's been going on with you
lately man well interestingly enough to
feel really good at the moment thank you
I had something to do with that this is
awesome guys thanks so much for having
me on this you know we've been chatting
for a couple minutes before went on
and it's already been a blast but I'm
having fun man I'm surrounded by do you
see what's going on out here
did you see what's going on right now I
don't want to mess my mic up here but
because I know it can be sensitive but
we got some listen listen listen I
already knew what was happening
someone's iPhone I'm telling you right
now this guy is my kid you invite over
the house cuz he had all the credit or
are you basically you would flavor but
like mercy 20 you know what it is I
really don't think guys of you know
children I'm not gonna bother him
because is nothing like a Kenner toy or
is nothing like you know she's jet
Armstrong town oh it's just it's just
nothing like you know throwing on a toy
at somebody and it's made out of pure
metal then it's actually giving them
that feeling of you know don't mess with
me because toys was also weapons when we
were growing up Megatron was real back
do you guys know that the Japanese
Megatron actually shot pellets
Noorie yeah they pulled that in the
North America it's not just like a
realistic gun it's actually shooting at
people
Wow people start a new masterwork toys
right I think I send one to you god oh
is it is a guy in Japan Japan line of
masterwork transformers you know the
Megatron actually has a sound like it
does the change into it actually shoots
out pellets and it's really different
when you construct them they really look
like the cartoon and it really has a
voice you know he met Ron it's very nice
I'm loving this room show
and you already know we have the Four
Horsemen of gaming see sure I would
racket it today those original Lords of
the realm here at the round table
my co-host with the co lost my brother
from another mother the difficult game
conqueror Lord of reviews and the house
of the young wolf my man Lord added back
off the sick bad man are you doing I'm
not quite off this sick bed I have like
a stumble man like I got up a little bit
and fell back down but you know
definitely doing a lot better than I did
was last week didn't even really get to
play a whole lot man like I wasn't even
playing Pokemon that's how sick I was
I wasn't played but what's funny is we
meet I mean look hard even got on
destiny of the day he's like I'm only
like level 25 or 26 on you sees that
he's like man your love was like I had
the flu other than that just trying to
get on the road to recovery people
missed you man we missed you man look
man I don't know what the I I didn't
exist last week a shadow ro no I I
almost everyone could get it like my
boss coming at me for missing word you
can get it you can get it that the
dollar store cashier could get it I
didn't care at that point we glad you're
back but real quick got to show that to
my brother double-barrel gang mr.
boomstick XL he said did someone say GI
Joe at Transformers those are my two
favorite toys in the 80s and OH
basically everything that's why we got
the man what if you see where she's
gonna break it down for us it's crazy
it's crazy today so that's what's up man
but good that attic is back you know
keep it going and of course we have our
most technical gaming Lord the solo game
owners for the single player selfish
experience and also the sastra Damas
mister off my profile Illuminati and
lore patron of the iron bank my man Lord
sovereign are you doing sir - good
what's going on
good afternoon gentlemen pretty good
really good despite not sleeping much
you know a little bit of sleep and
working on that 10 hour energy that I
just drink
what if I told you about of our Gosselin
to those at once it's a bad situation
right now
by the end of the show how bad a baby's
babies in there that's what's up Luke
lordy and simply go bad big games
all right see you pax eath boys in that
all right you know we gonna beat it is
gonna be funny gaming actually nothing
until this morning and I finally finally
they're running right now finishing this
control next up on the single player one
is the Star Wars Oh get up be happy with
me my question what's up oh please say
somebody on this panel got into plague
tale this week please know I think I
played like five hours of play tail I
kind of dropped it so so sorry you been
so you were to hold off a lot to say
about it yeah I don't know I want to see
cuz I I think I said it when I was
talking about the end before I don't
think it's a you guys game but it is a
game that if Microsoft still considering
buying Studios their Studios should be
looked at
yeah and of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the XS gamer
mmm the Lord of combat sports king of
the statues who demands nothing less
than that premium experience it is the
leader of the fraud alert movement mmm
beloved lucky guy you can exert I'm
doing incredible
listen combat talk real quick we had
some fights yesterday that I was really
excited about because the week before we
had j-rock get rocked by banana paws oh
so last night we had Jared hurt and his
fight and it was a get back fight
because you know the last fight that he
had he lost to j-rock he lost the title
to j-rock and um it could have been one
of those fights with you know Jared
heard definitely slipped on a banana
peel no pun intended and he didn't you
know he came through with shining colors
he looked a little bit different he
showed a good jab a good right hand a
good technical know-how instead of just
brawling his way through he's probably
next up for one of the charlo brothers
China will be something interesting to
see we also had Danny Garcia getting
back daddy loves and listen let me tell
you guys anytime you hear your favorite
writers say these words this is a line
of caution oh I fell in love again with
the sport oh yeah yeah right
yo that's real talk you are right about
yes that's Mike Michael yeah but the
Buddy side yes wouldn't with money that
means I'm fighting this bum and I had to
pull myself off of my silk sheets
entertainment is the difference between
sleeping on silk and sleeping on kind
it's an old fight proverb right when
you're sleeping on silk right he's
sleeping on cotton is rough and you
trying to fight to get to that silk
I saw Danny was sleeping on the floor
that'll make it very hungry and that's
how banana won that fight pause um but
Danny said he got on the scale before he
started training camp and he was 25
pounds overweight and he was eating good
he said he it was the most realistic
interview after a fight I've ever seen
he goes because you know Jim Jim asked
him you know um Jim great did you go
yeah do you think you did he said I I
don't think I did really good I did 12
rounds I wanted to knock out I couldn't
get it he said maybe this because this
camp was like a weight-loss camp and I
wasn't really training
oh you know and that yep but it's real
talk you know and a lot of these guys
got to understand it when your journey
is over in sports right that's when you
can relax right now while you're
fighting not while you're training not
while you're doing anything you can't
relax then because let me tell you
something to somebody behind you that's
not relaxed and that's sleeping on the
cotton sheets or sleeping on that floor
and Danny found out if Danny had fought
arrow spent last night Danny would have
been massacred all right he'd have been
hung from the highest tree and we would
have saw Danny's body
no okay so hopefully Danny you know
understands exactly what he needs to do
to get it done all right so what's going
on all for that combat talk stuff I
don't know a lot of you guys is cringed
oh shut up the cyborgs she did a thing
mr. blades yeah all right Pete ABS I'm
saying the jump in cowboy took a dive
because the world on the street is no
cowboy took a dive for the dough I don't
think so I'm just asking
there's too much integrity to do that
now okay thank you because I thought I
kind of really gave him yeah woody yeah
I'll just do something we've never saw
before people just don't want to give it
up there don't like it
all right so check this out guys mm-hmm
all right so I'm in game pass right now
anybody that's trying to shame me for
investing in game Pass
I'm not buying no games sorry I don't I
don't I don't care how you feel about it
I don't care if you cry you scream King
you not a true gamer I was gaming on
controllers when it was one joystick
enough talk about it what I do is just
that don't don't even try I'm certified
my junior crush the rebels um but you
guys really don't get it the level of
value that's inside game pass is nuts
because yeah I can do something stupid
like one month by pay $500 for a bunch
of games that came out and I'm only
gonna get a chance to play one and by
the time I get around to play some game
it's like $9.99 someplace in game stop
right no but see what game you pass dud
for me because they I played this game
called children of Mordor if you have
not played this game and if no world
wouldn't actually a really fun game it
is a day I wanted to talk to you about
it so bad because it is if this is if
you like some 16-bit games nice the game
is how a 16-bit retro games supposed to
feel in this day and age falls to you
guys the whole way through Philly Eagles
breathe you said children what is number
two of 2019 most Miley said King I've
been loving your tweets lately chad is
about you
I've been I've been I've been trying to
slay these dudes in these streets it's a
lot of false narratives going on because
they'd like to tell you that game pass
doesn't have any value and like
sovereigns said plague tail is there I
downloaded plague tales I downloaded
this game called invisible then I'm
gonna be or indivisible and yeah and it
was another game there that I'm going to
dive into but is the fact that there's
so much value that I even went out now
and I'm not gonna front I got my little
Negro bucks coming I'm sorry but I'm the
only time I'm gonna spend money when I
get my little Negro reward and I went
out and I brought on Star Wars uh which
was John yeah the Jedi had a form in
order because that most likely probably
won't go into game pad no because EA
access oh no they won't because the
y-axis right but I have the a axis as
well but I doubted it reached there
because I was playing battlefront
and I was on my Star Wars real because
this Jedi movie was oh my god right so
I'm just like so Star Wars doubt right
now I'm and I'm reading these Vader
books like I was talking to our
illustrious guest today and I'm telling
you right now yeah that game is going to
probably be game of the year when I'm
finished with it because I started it up
and it gave me the feeling of the Force
Unleashed nice and which is right you
ain't seen nothing yet this is it like
people are telling me that this is
arguably the best Star Wars game ever
made like I got a question go for it
yeah how does it compare to super Empire
Strikes Back for Super Nintendo
see see see this is this is where I had
on put Force Unleashed so high because
those are Super NES games who captured
the whole field all wars for me but then
when I got to the force on least what it
did was it changed you know nights all
Republic
was probably the top for us at that time
until Force Unleashed came on my issues
I got problem playing games that are
older one of the things I learned early
in life was that music made before I was
born is awesome and that grabbe's ago
somewhere to educate words appling and
so that opened my eyes to hey maybe
everything or a lot of things before I
was born things that were written or or
you know movies so yeah that don't ever
let that disqualify they talk did he
talk to you stuff his little ears turned
off are you small the holes inside is
small oh definitely played a whole bunch
of stuff and I definitely got into my
destiny so of course we have the gaming
ninja himself the shinobi who actually
picked up shinobi this week on the Laura
kognito I'm spreading that realness in
the realm of the IOP not telling you
what you want to hear but what you need
to hear shots a JD game with the two our
super chat have y'all heard the rumors
of a new cult oi yes it's looking pretty
pretty good too yes looking pretty good
because Disney actually they they they
reverse that we're you know revin is
actually canon now so you really like
the ocean oh they brush Sega and those
dudes they were doing a good job with
the ports over an internal switch so you
know I gotta have shinobi on every
platform every system I even got the
arcade cabinet kick those back in the
curve of the world
the originals I wasted all my quarters
you know so shout out that I shot the
real Taj online we had some good Sega
discussion we talked about Street
rage and um what's this guy's name solve
you that the composer a sound composer
for Streets of Rage use old who you use
okashira Kushiro
yo I learned a lot about him bad I
learned a lot about him I know Lord
Michael mercy you have a great video
let's rearrange you've done some Let's
Plays legit
yes playthroughs liquors for / 1 & 2
yeah yeah my favorite games ever bro
it's crazy how well the music stands up
yeah you machine part one specially in
one I just had an argument with silver
cuz I say yo low-key even though recent
rage 2 is the better game 1 has the
better music and my so here's that's I
feel the same way and then when I played
3 I was like what is this
someone told me you got to check out
this fan-made thing called Streets of
Rage remake and that's the masterpiece
because they took the gameplay of 2 & 3
took the music of all three of them but
of one like the orchestra remastered
live versions of part 1 yes you're on
the boat but with the graphics of part 2
Orchestra version of that let's go
listen yo I'm actually super hyper I
want to shout out to all these guys uh
DotEmu who's actually responsible for
the streets of for that she's Rex for
that's gonna come out who Sega has given
the green light to who they are brought
they actually saw I just found out they
got Yuzo Koshiro and all the old guys
that did the music involved with the
project so yeah we're gonna yeah we got
to be to those guys we to get them on
it's gonna be lit man I can't with
stitch you're going to stop that put
bushes in the chat just cuz I said it's
on a switch its PlayStation it's on Xbox
so you can throw those wishes away well
yeah that's what I've been doing anyway
we got a lot of show so now that we've
gotten to what the Lord's have been
please I want to start with Lord Michael
merci his video game system history his
passion for all eighties retro and of
course the journey will let him to the
amazing michael mercy youtube channel so
let's start from the beginning
skips let's start with some of the first
video game systems you had and what got
you into gaming well i one of the first
games i've ever played like at the
arcade i didn't get to go to the arcade
much right as a little kid it's you know
parents were worried don't go in there
you know get into some kind of trouble
um but we had like donut shops and stuff
that had the table anyone remember the
table video yes down with the glass-top
pac-man so that's that's my first gaming
experience is pac-man Donkey calling
that stuff and then um
we we had like at one point pong it
wasn't like swap different cartridges in
there and play it was it played one
thing that's how school I am my coke
also played one game and the paddles had
no buttons Wow right yep so that after
that it was Atari 2600 and that was yeah
the one button so many good games on
that jungle hunt
remember the vines and now yes and then
there were bad games too that I remember
fondly like Raiders of the Lost Ark
listen I the bulk of my atari 2600
library was gotten after they went under
and they were like 50 cents a pop like a
hundred games in one shot the sedgwick h
with the tails which i show it some love
before o'clock it thank you brother much
appreciated continue this is good man
i'm remembering a lot of great games for
2600 phoenix where you pull back and
it's a forcefield yars revenge with the
weird lights and study messed around did
you go for
well then you had to make choice because
like you know my my cousin had a
colecovision illegals on television is
actually good so that was that was my
first exposure to the game wars where
you had to pick a side G you know
ignorant when you say my side is better
than your side but in that case the turi
really was better than ColecoVision cuz
i had like 25 awesome games or so and
and my cousin had like two I guess I got
a fanboy yeah with the phone the
controller was amazing like all the
buttons on the guitar like I got one if
I have it basically a touchpad phone
with knob buttons in the circular you
know what I loved about Coleco is all
the games came with that little like a
little pad that you slide into the
controller and it had a different button
for different things by far Atari was
the more popular sister I will bend the
knee on now there was this weird little
blip that happened before the Nintendo
came out and a Sega Master System anyone
remember Atari 7800 yes I had that I had
Atari foot I had twenty six hundred
fifty two hundred and seventy eight
hundred yeah so that came out and I
remember being really pumped for that
like oh my god the next level of Atari
evolution and that was like okay all the
games on that were it was a night day
right I thought it would be arcade level
but then um it came time to make a
decision between NES and Sega Master
System and that's where like the game
Wars people were drawing a line in the
sand and they're you know fist fights at
school
no not really
here you're doing your donuts you know
[Laughter]
but we went with NES and I think it in
the long run it was the right call
because again kind of like with Atari
and Coleco Master System great system
but titles it's just the titles were
there in NES exclusion and I could talk
with you 10 hours about NES Zelda link
to the past all the Metal Gear Oh could
you go early Cagiva let's go oh dear
yeah you coherent stop it before you
fell off the wagon it's sure it went
from a practical espionage action to
existential yeah you need to get on Tim
Tam it's a Pokemon on PC but what's the
new Pokemon should have been PS stitch
and I love stitch and his switch Lander
that's actually pretty pretty funny
because um I've been watching Tintin
stream use it debating if I want to pull
that trigger because you're I actually
seen like ninja was playing like like a
month ago the person who's doing all the
the you know distributing all the codes
and stuff he hit me up I was just like
I'm at this time I was playing Pokemon
and I was like why would I play generic
Pokemon no thank you
after it comes out of like shadow DJ DJ
with to our Supercop Vectrex and odyssey
rubber odyssey oh my real classic yo
salut je d I remember Odyssey yo JD that
Vectrex I think that was my prize and I
got I remember who I got it from too
because I made a super trade and I made
my trade and I got it and the cartridge
is winning inside and I play I used to
go plugging aside on the wall in the
house and it had the extension cord and
I will run it outside in the hallway and
I was set out with my friends playing it
because that was the only self contained
video game system and I was the I was
the belle of the ball
[Laughter]
dad won me it put me over the top that
you have to come their love with this
old-school retro talk pixel bit geo
lords I need to get y'all on I think
it's slime rancher I'll forget you get
shot up on that slime wrong yes must my
son got that for his birthday this is
one of the pissed off days that I had my
son has game pass and he made me go to
game stop winning 1st birthday because
you can't say no to a kid on his
birthday we spend $100 in real life cash
out of my pocket to buy games that I
know will be on Katie Smith final chat
Legend of Zelda with the gold cartridge
by Cooper yes that was a game-changer in
the first few months of the game
remember when that thing came out that
the NES was new all the games and
cartridges are new and then all the
sudden you got a chrome gold cartridge
that's a Majora's Mask one and I have
the NES one yeah it was something about
like you say mercies like you had that
gold cartridge and then what was kind of
unique I think at the time got a battery
inside it was the first game that I
remember that you
save your save state that was a big deal
for it that was huge
that was like it was a play to game you
just turn the screen or but leave it on
and tell your mother don't touch it
don't touch it how about how about mom
calling dinner's ready come and eat
there's no pause yes when I first got
Final Fantasy 8 on the ps1 I didn't have
a memory card I remember I got to this
it was mad far into that and it was back
in the day like if you put a memory card
in that if it didn't start with it in it
yo was ever gonna register you have to
like format it or something like that
it's no it's not that it's just if you
didn't start with the memory card in the
console it didn't recognize it so I had
to start that whole when I brought my
PlayStation the first one and the
Japanese import remember cuz it came out
months before and um he was selling the
memory cause I think was like that's
what made you know Xbox the original
building was good hey cog I feel like a
Verizon can you hit me now and kick
David you stopping me from getting by
Steven Spielberg on fax great show
brother I'd know whether way we've been
playing phone tag I got you bro I got
you we will definitely get that gone but
we got to continue with Lord Michael
mercy going through the history we got
to the NES now up until that point did
you keep going or where was your game
history that way well after a couple
years of NES oh it's time to upgrade to
either Super Nintendo or Genesis so
history keeps repeating I mean once you
get a little long in the tooth you get a
couple of gray whiskers all the stuff
that people get so worked up every
single year you become kind of like
grandpa back there going
seen it seen it 50 times
it's not it's not as intense and you
know doesn't get your heart racing as
much the 50th time you see it so Super
Nintendo Genesis I went with Genesis
wasn't I wasn't brand loyal I was I was
when I saw Sonic and Streets of Rage
decision made now sonic in the long run
didn't end up brother I have placed rage
like within the last two weeks and I
probably play it every two weeks I play
it on the computer emulator I play it on
my like little PlayStation Portable you
know it like yes you can play that game
I got it on my phone it's got no buttons
I don't know how to play it you like
you're supposed to Oh amazing there's
another great game for Genesis called
war song which no one remembers but it
was the bull like battle strategy game
it had everything it had run and jump it
had fight and it also had think you know
like RPGs and strategy stuff like that
but after a couple years I could not
deny the ops awesomeness of Super
Nintendo so I got one of those too my
brother and I got a Super Nintendo and
that's what I don't get about these
video game wars and I know not everyone
can have both but sometimes if you work
hard enough and you save enough and you
don't you know drink or do the other
things that just kind of burn through
your money nah
marcantel an entire generation there's
no reason why someone can't get both
today I mean it was I don't have both
you just you're just not trying to have
both at that point but she financially
back then is different is a different
ball wasn't it like it was like a seven
hundred dollar system back then like it
was a paycheck you know he's talking
about present time like why you don't
have both if you you know why yeah like
if I hop onto my here in Canada we call
it cats it's you know you buy
second-hand stuff it's like Craigslist
okay um so I had a ps3 that died and
that sucked cuz I had like ten great
games for it I wanted to play my
ghostbusters again I wanted to pay my
toll Gear Solid four again and it died
the and it was like my second ps3 that
died the blu-ray thing burned on it I
jumped on Kijiji and I found one
secondhand used for a hundred bucks
that's Canadian that's like what is it
35 cents u.s. I mean there's no reason
like I did like he was saying um I don't
have an Xbox 360 because I choose not to
it's not because I can't it's just you
know I'm not as much into modern gaming
so especially now how Black Friday sales
be happening like they just gave out a
PlayStation for $200 of like four games
and we're not talking about like you
know for reach to the bar of the barrel
games we're talking about like four of
the best games that came out the gist
system sellers yeah this discussion a
lot you know a lot of it comes down to
finances and people make choices and
then they lock in as a result so you
have that brand loyalty but the reality
if if the if the deck was clear and
money was no object and you had the
ability to get both people with the
console was what exists because they
would have the the perspective of both
things and can respect both sides but
because people are locked in they like
you i gotta justify this choice I gotta
make a the cult mentality the mentality
of you know my way is the best way and
you start to get the hive mind and you
know if you don't go
with us and you must be ostracized I
think a really healthy mentality to have
is you can make up your mind you can do
your research and make a decision but I
think a healthy way of looking at it is
you make your decision so I went back
then I'm going to decide to go with the
Genesis but it could be wrong right
you leave that window open so that
you're not you know right that dead set
and then someday when you change your
mind based on new criteria cuz times
change and mmm-hmm
change and and you know people pulling a
finger and say you're a hypocrite you're
a hypocrite but if you leave that window
open but I could be mistaken and no one
could ever call you a hypocrite as you
go well I left the window open what kind
of [ __ ] doesn't leave a window fire
were you gonna go for the stand point up
even if you make that decision right
it's like it's okay to say you know what
I made the decision I did the research
right but it's okay let me go over King
sophomore song let's go to King's house
he's got the other system right let's
just see what's going on and we missed
out on whatever and this way you can
have kind of like a balanced perspective
in a lot of people they just close their
minds people especially how big YouTube
is they know what the other ones doing
they just want to throw this not false
narrative oh I can't afford it yeah but
you spent $800 on that iPhone in your
head shut up do me a favor get that we
got some super chats from Titan I
believe in stitch once from tight yeah
he just says 100 you get stitch okay so
we got a we got a $2.00 uh well $9.99
from stitch I wish I knew about memory
cards when I was younger I finished
Resident Evil One and Metal Gear Solid
in a single session because every time I
died I had to restart so I've memorized
the game the struggle man I don't I
don't even envy why you respect that man
if you said that you did that Resident
Evil on one shot homie
listen I'm playing Resident Evil 2 right
now and he would tell you what I was
playing this week with that
resume with two right now boom I'm mad
at you I'm playing a resume with two and
I'm so pissed off because I cleared off
everything right and I did this one
thing and then my house started filling
up with zombies again and my bullets is
low so that's gay this resin evil right
here forces you I couldn't even think
about not having no memory savings on
this I think I think if you finish
resident evil one in one shot you might
as well play too because you're not good
[Laughter]
now I know like you said when it came to
modern gaming you kind of slow down
because if you want to share it cuz it
wasn't like the it was a demotion 3d
games like I can't I don't know why I
can't handle it I was I was right there
with everybody you know neck-and-neck
contra and and all that stuff man final
fight streets of rage and then ps1 came
out and and that was another game
changer it was y-you know next literally
next level stuff like they were doing
stuff on ps1 that no console before it
could dream of doing play person
shooters and stuff and I'm like
everyone's having fun and I'm like oh I
need to go to the bathroom like I come
back and I'm like the room is spinning
I'm like but I want to have fun write
this stuff is amazing and you know like
despite how I'm feeling I'm realizing oh
this is great and I'm like oh my god I
gotta lay down and I'm a kid right I'm
like what am I feeling like so I don't I
don't know why but I can I can handle it
in small doses and depending on the game
maybe it has something to do with
framerate and stuff cuz Mad Max I played
that thing all the way through oh and it
was pretty good with that like I did you
know have nothing VR at all no I haven't
checked that out
do not try one thought I would go over
be off listen listen
get that stuff on eBay after you pass
away listen just get the top shelf on
get the vibe right and just sit there
and merge yourself listen and just have
a bucket if you go on here's an idea for
VR game so you put the thing on you're
sitting in a room there's a bucket
beside you and so in real life you have
a bucket too so it's kind of like you
know you never forget the buckets thing
so yeah there's some ps1 games that I
can like Metal Gear Solid I didn't it
because that's like a traditional over
the head yes like the game and that's
one of the greatest games of all time I
put that right up there streets rage
that was like this is a movie a movie
like what what is this and in in other
games like in computer games which we
haven't talked about either there'd be
like cutscenes and sometimes you could
feel like yawn I want to play a game I
don't want to watch a game but when it
came to Metal Gear Solid I was like I
got to get over with this you know let's
get this over with is shooting in
jumping you get back but I want to watch
the story was in his bag man definitely
cinematic storytelling he definitely
changed the game we can't take that away
from in his early stages what he was
doing with Konami and those Metal Gear
games with tremendous then he made death
strange oh I think PlayStation allowed a
different level of expression that
developers weren't able to achieve prior
to the PlayStation coming out and I
think Navi made it to go on regular
check-ups well no I mean he formulated a
lot of our old us older um gamers and
history because if you listen to him say
because this is like the third time he
spoke about metal gear and it must
impact in him in such a way that you
know Kojima was able to go if not full
Kojima he went partial Kojima and ever
go fool because you yeah well he went
full kijima with deaf gender for what I
hear I don't know but he goes would you
call Metal Gear Solid 5 full gajima yeah
I think I think meat was Moses the sons
of the Patriots is what he started to
lead into his philosophical Illuminati
bag and I was just like yeah when there
were so many little snakes and they were
all different people it started getting
confusing and then I had to go to
youtube to watch the story over to at
the part where I was probably falling
asleep mentally to gain some form of
traction with him because I'm I was
trying to follow him because you know
Lee like man I could follow him and then
it just got to the point where is like
that room again I told you cog yeah like
everybody is doing doobies in the room
he definitely lost some people at that
point I mean we can't take away his
early contributions though he definitely
changed the game a lot of ways just real
quick blubbers I wanted to ask you um I
know you briefly talked about our case
before do you wanna skip over it like
did you did you have any experience I
know you said the parents didn't like
you to go but did you have any
experience at all going or trying to you
know experience big-time big-time like
eventually when I got a little bit of
older I could go but you know I I didn't
have a lot of dough so I did a lot of
watching it was kind of like the the
arcade for me was like
Toys R Us yes I didn't have an issue
with you know just kind of standing and
watching over someone's shoulder because
I mean if I had the choice of wasting a
quarter and getting destroyed in a video
game 22nd drag dragons quest what was it
called again yeah the one you don't play
the one that plays you yes if I had the
choice of wasting a quarter in like 10
seconds or any other game you know 15
seconds or a minute of getting destroyed
or getting me to stand there and watch a
guy play awesome for 20 minutes for free
free or free 99 and that's what I really
miss about arcades the you know some of
those guys even in your own little town
could be like rock stars
yeah flock theorem on row I literally
just had a talking to a developer
yesterday I posted a clip of me playing
she told me on the switch and I recorded
one of the hardest segments it was like
a boss fight and I remember like this
boss fight used to terrorize me so
what's funny is people like yo they were
commenting on my on my tweet and then
people people like hey man I just I
didn't have the confidence to play those
games I used to just watch and I said
trust me that's how I started because
there was a kid in my neighborhood that
he basically he was so good at shinobi
that when he would come to play the
whole block with an encompass to arcade
right and he would use one quarter a
game his name was dog they used to call
him shinobi don't this is all one six
seven K is what ya know so I was like yo
he's on me one day I gotta be that good
you told me the whole story what is your
fixation with the shinobi I mean I get
it the news he was know what the whole
arcade Michelle Laura told me get mercy
bro he was a rock star like whoever was
in your hood that your area and they
were nice at that game they were rock
star they were
here you know they shot the J boys shout
to skanky you already don't be oh please
please tell me while he was playing he
was also signing autographs listen shut
up the Cognito for not caring when the
move-in guys came to bring his arcade
machine he lived all the way upstairs at
the top of his house and he made them
take it up those narrow steps and they
broke they back cuz I know they did then
arcade machine was like five so continue
they should all be done thing did you
like okay
then the next thing was like one day I'm
gonna write so I was dig my research it
was on eBay I found like an old Texas
arcade distributor and they were like
this one in our case he was dead and
they're like giving these things away
and he had the full authentic cabinet a
bike and I'm like dude I gotta get it
was he was selling for like a hundred
bucks
he was just like you gotta pay for the
shipping so me stupid me thinking that
you know you just pay for the shipping
and they're gonna do the rest so a big
truck or a bunch like a big optimus
prime truck comes down my narrow block
in the South Bronx right on freight 3d
plates drops it off and leave what are
you doing brother
our job is done we just the Freak
shippers so I said oh no so that I had
to call moving guys and I'm like look I
got arcade unit I'm on the fourth floor
this building like I me and it's gonna
there's no elevator lobby game now right
brother
all right bro you got you got so they
got the two most biggest guys and this
is what our small kindnesses skinny cuz
I wasn't lifting anything back to lift
it up for flights I had to pay those
guys like 200 bucks you should have paid
them in video games
[Laughter]
[Music]
anymore in the game the [ __ ] was the
shipping was about yeah at least three
at least 300 the game was only 100 the
shipper was like because they were
shipping it from Texas and they act
their Freight out put it on those plays
I had to call King and I had to call mr.
Hogg nobody came off with this he
thought he thought on this earth that
mean how was mr. mr. Murphy I'm sorry
but I know when Mortal Kombat came to
your town because everybody has that
story when you went to the arcade and so
Mortal Kombat the first one for the
first time could you please walk me
through your experience with this
because it's in the chill I must buy I
so true horror and my's the first time I
saw it
my question to you was what was your
experience with the Phenom of Mortal
Kombat you know that song
the is it a song the end of innocence
[Laughter]
cuz man games were fun colorful you
basically cartoons that you could play
and then Mortal Kombat and then the guy
pulling the heart out and the guy
yanking a spline out finish him and the
guy falling on the spikes and it was a
blast
but oh but you know deep down I knew
something has changed here going this
way and we just did this here we are
that was taped out how crazy is there
oh let me go over the okay sir I gotta
get a Guinness movie cuz oh man this is
it would be a memory lane for so long
but I had to get going and I want to
talk about obviously what you know for
which is everything eighties retro thing
that's so cool is like again looking
behind you that amazing toy collection
we're seeing stuff from my group the GI
Joes the transformers nor lad like what
inspired that toy collection and then
obviously your channel well um I was
really into toys when I was a kid I got
as many as I could we were on a tight
budget so I I've always tried to get a
lot of bang for my buck going right back
to deciding which GI Joe am I gonna get
so looking at the Joe's and I'm like and
they all look so cool you know stalker
was awesome loved his outfit but he had
one gun right and it's helmet is good
more he hadn't cooperate but I wanted
like accessories I'm like you know next
time baby I'll get you next time I went
with breaker cuz backpack helmet the
thing on the helmet and yeah got as many
Joes as it could transformers were
really expensive and you couldn't have a
lot of them they were like a special
birthday or Christmas gift yes
and then like most people like as I got
older that stuff goes in a box or it
goes to kids of friends or you know your
dad's friends mom's friends kids and it
just went in a box for a while but there
was always a couple that I held on to
because like even when you're young you
know you can have a little bit of
nostalgia for like five years ago or ten
years ago you know I think it's
hilarious when I see young people have
nostalgia for something two years ago
they see an old post of a post from six
months ago and man those were the good
old days
Aurel you know before life got you know
serious but I held on to snake eyes you
know I held on to storm shadow yeah we
were talking that ideas were so long we
try to figure out that that patient
special mission and you did the two that
shoot I wanted to do you did already
it's such a phenomenal job which was the
Devastator which is my favorite chance
for her and then the Megatron g1
Devastator still coming but when you I
said you know what I never had anyone
really take a deep dive with Storm
Shadow you know say it again actually
cool and we talked about it and you did
such a tremendous you taught me things I
didn't know about the character that's
how extensive it was and then again the
little Norse is the the sound cues that
the sayings that he has and you don't
really like you you killed it you killed
it I want to shout you out on that
because they care that you do with your
video this is why people to understand
how beloved you are they care that you
take the intricacy the time it is so
thought out and the research done man
tremendous job so when I Lord salute you
we got to do it officially Nerdist a on
camera Michael mercy on anyway thank you
brother I was tremendous thank you guys
I thank you for that request and I never
know how a video was gonna turn out when
I do it I like Storm Shadow a lot before
I did that one but when I was done I was
like I love Storm Shadow a lot I learned
a lot doing that too because I just I
dive into the well and I go let's see
how deep it is sometimes it's you know
not that deep sometimes it's pretty deep
and sometimes it's M endless and then
when I got to the second storm shadow
figure I decided this video isn't the
history of storm shadow this is 80's
edition history of storm show is there's
nineties there's there's awesome
teens and like this this needs to go on
and on cuz this character he's got a lot
of gas in the tank
on awesome complex character both both
in the comic as well as the cartoon and
yep didn't it didn't have that many
complex it's good and evil yes and and
stupid
it is weird character who who's on Cobra
but has this weird blurt say honor and
you know it just respect as a villain it
just such a crazy big at the time but it
was really cool because it was so so
unique yeah so I had like a few guys
here and there that I held onto but then
as the years went on like I had a shelf
so I had a shelf of he-man and
transformers and some others yeah and
then one shelf turned to two and to turn
to three and then and you're like
looking at a wall going I think I may
have overdone it and then fast forward
to today and I look around and I go
there's there's a little space left lady
Bercy she actually supports you I was
like how did you get her evolved to like
cuz again I be a king smoke cake smoked
earlier like you know sometimes it's
hard to get your significant other to
participate in your passion like how did
you get her locked linked in this is one
thing that I always bring up in a lot of
my videos the truth is I wouldn't be
with her if she wasn't like that I made
my choice that's you know I made my
choice before you know we got married
and and I think everybody needs to do
that
and I've heard the stories of people
going you know my girlfriend my wife my
husband whatever
they won't put up with it they don't get
it they don't like it they tolerate it
and everyone I'm always saying to each
his own to each her own do do what makes
you happy do what feels right to you but
tolerance doesn't feel right to me like
I I don't want someone to tolerate what
I'm passionate about
Oh talks about really some really wrong
to me about something makes you
genuinely happy and it's not hurting
anybody you know like it's it's good
stuff it's inspiring it's empowering and
it makes you a better person or want to
be a better person try to be a better
person help people and there's someone
over there going okay what a burden I
have to put up with your passion for
this stuff I just decided early on those
set that people aren't for me and that's
I'm talking a relationship and I'm
talking friends walks into this room and
they go wow that's crazy
you really have too much time on your
hands I'm like well you can just turn
right around and walk out the door
because that's not a friend you know I'm
so let you good again King and I've had
this discussion if you're not on that
path that we're on you know I'm saying
it's like I don't have that much time
because this is what my journey this is
my path I love this stuff we love gaming
if you're not happy when this gigantic
gauntlet shows up at the door as much as
I am you can leave outside that door
[Music]
with the $20 to love casa de lourdes
live even if it's only for a few minutes
I mean Lord salute my man Lord Jameson
that's what's up man shout the phase
he's like yo who is this guy
I'm like this is Michael mercy I gave
him a YouTube channel link so people
know that's what's going to his channel
when I came in today because you know we
have like a pre warm-up before we start
and you know I was already um prepped on
his stuff and and I have a friend my
brother Danny I got a tattoo on my hand
and I'm shipped home but I looked and I
said see you see
it's a kinship I get it and I was like
touching through the screen like a
brother is on the other side and he's in
Canada to my mom his room is magnificent
is it's it's a thing to behold that he
told you that's he made a decision long
ago hope this is him love him how he is
because I mean I'm sorry if you lose
those parts of yourself who are you hell
are you my wife she's you know she's not
as intensely passionate about GI Joe and
transformers but the important thing is
that she she enjoys it through me and
it's what I call empathy right she you
can in you can enjoy someone's joy so
just because you know like if you're
into x-men or Avengers and the other
person isn't like you can still be happy
around a happy person and if you're
unhappy around a happy person there
might be something wrong with you there
might be a lack of empathy you know it
might be a narcissistic personality
disorder
yeah it's true like there are some
people you know who you date or whatever
and whatever they're passionate that you
may not know anything about it right but
what Lord Michael mercy is saying is so
true if you see how much joy it brings
them you should be like yo I got to
either learn something about it or I
just like to see them in their happy
place right you should be like huh when
it's just gonna be over you know say
like like that's the problem with you
you don't say like you're not happy that
your significant other is happy like
that's crazy
Jared the brat with Utah super chef he
is dropping knowledge another one oh
yeah oh yeah preach cake cake
here's here's where I can go to cuz it
goes both ways and when I met my wife
she was a huge Star Trek fan I was like
treks okay I wasn't crazy about it but
because she respects the things that I'm
passionate about I it goes both ways
give what you get and you get what you
give so I would sit down and we'd watch
Trek together and we went through all a
Voyager and I started a really like Star
Trek with all the TNG and I started to
really love Star Trek and now we
together love Star Trek I didn't love
Star Trek why I love it because of her
that's fine oh that's why we do this the
Trek stuff on the channel too and that's
where it can go like if someone gives
you the respect you give it back and
everybody wins
because she's learned so much about all
the stuff that I'm into and I've learned
so much about all the stuff that she's
into isn't that what being a human being
is about doing more instead of just
crossing your arms and going no I'm done
I made up my mind and this is all that
I'll ever need yo they are killing us
they call us the island love podcast
they said oh relationship with the Lords
they were like love hour with it we drop
the relationship bombs in here yo I got
one more quote I want to share here I
use it all the time it's by a dude named
Elbert Hubbard and when I heard this
light went off in my head because it
applied to so much stuff in my life I've
used it for 15 years now and it's
awesome he said never explain your
friends don't need it and your enemies
won't believe you anyway so when a good
brother there was explaining about game
paths and the people not getting it
don't explain you just you put your
hands up you put your feet up and and
you wait and you watch and you go let's
see if I need to explain if you get it
or if you don't get it the people who
don't get it they're not your friends
why bother why bother trying to win
/ because even if it seems like you do
you think in the long run those people
have your back the next time there's
something that needs an explanation
lord have mercy I'll call you there
bursty traffic knowledge today all of it
this is this fantastic real quick
question just two more that we wrote rap
but um I have to ask you again with the
special missions you have again
tremendous patreon tribe these
tremendous individualized videos that
you do for people but I I call you the
cool kid on the block that everybody
want to play toys with that's what I'm
your kid that we everyone want delirious
cuz I had barely any toys I was at other
people's houses but I can tell you is
having fun you guy could tell so like
what is the inspiration from for you as
far as this being so accurate you know
saying like doing that research like
what gets you into that dead zone it
just feels like this material deserves
it you know to use Storm Shadow as an
example when I started doing the
research which you know it's such a
clinical word for something that was
actually really a lot of fun and and
enjoyable to read about and learn about
the character so we're talking about the
writing that Larry Hamm I put into the
comic and he created the character the
history the personality of him and then
we go to the cartoon totally different
team but they also looked at him and
went this is a deep important special
character this isn't just one of the
deke GI Joe guys you're like come on
Jose we gotta save the day like really
special character and then you look at
the sculpting on the figure and that's
that's not a guy just doing that in two
hours and he's done I'm gonna go have
lunch a lot of effort and artistry went
into all of the storm shadow figures I
can't look at all of this creativity and
respect that went into it and and go I'm
gonna bang this out in an hour
it deserves more and I just you know I I
like to you know live my life in the you
get what you give and you give what you
get it doesn't
often work out that way but in the
things that I have power in that
character had a lot of love and a lot of
you know it was a job for a lot of
people but you can't deny there was a
lot of passion that went into it two
people cared people who created storm
shadow carrot and people who create a
optimist care all them guys I saw those
men even lion-o bravestarr
talk about heared it deserves the time
in the effort and so I'll give it my
time in my effort tremendous man this is
off this is amazing we can go on I got
two more and then we're down at home how
do you feel about stranger things have
you watched stranger things on Netflix
and if you have don't you sensitive
witty least nostalgia so is it does it
pass the test or is it like well here's
how here's how well it passes the test a
lot of this the YouTube channel thanks
to stranger things there you go I I knew
that was a fun happy time but when I
watch stranger things that's when I went
this is so different why does this feel
so different why is this so awesome so
good what are they doing different than
every other movie and TV show that's
doing a period piece you know like we
look at that 70 show is a fun show
mm-hmm but it doesn't like make you man
you know it's just a fun show but
stranger things I went this looks and
moves and feels and smells and sounds is
this lost yes like did they make this in
the 80s and someone misplaced it yeah
left it in the back of his van by
accident and thirty years later they
found it like this is too authentic to
have been made now none of the stuff
they do today the the little check lists
they keep a checklist we have to have
this type of character we have to have
this type of situation you know we need
to hit this demographic um strangers the
first season like the second and third
ones too but the first season was like
yeah
this is so authentic there's been no
corporate meddling or anything yes
and I was like that's what really made
me go I want more but there is no more
there's nothing today that's like this
so then I put in the a-team and then
damn it and then I put in MacGyver
I put in all those old shows and I was
like with that day writing that's
treehome here's one no one remembers but
it's awesome you got to check it out
Hardcastle and mcCormick well this is
see the thing is in my house right they
were certain there was certain shows
that were family shows you had watched
as a family right it wasn't a show that
I my stuff would watch by myself but
then when Mom and Dad had the TV
podcasts on mcCormick theme songs you'll
ever hear from any show you see what
they're doing now with um well Fantasy
Island they turn it into a horror that's
interesting twist on it I mean it would
be a horror thing basically you know
like Fantasy Island and then I can't
wait to see it because that used to be
one of my greatest shows and Fantasy
Island and I Love Lucy the reason why is
because um they had Hispanics and
prominent roles right and being that my
grandmother's Puerto Rican I've never
got a chance to see like Hispanic and
prominent roles on television but in
these two shows the you know Ricky
Ricardo he had a club baba Lou Bava
Ricardo Montalban a whole to Fantasy
Island
seriously slow me only chatez love it
this 80s all right yo he said MacGyver
could make a bomb out of chewing over
the paperclip greatest American hero in
the jack we got that Wow you killing it
right now I got a question for you you
guys anyone here like the a-team back in
the eighties who's seen the new a-team
well not new now but today yeah anyone
here like that one no I you know I
everyone teach it is I love that movie
and I thought like this perfectly
captures the spirit of the old show and
you know not a lot of stuff reboot shows
do like the new MacGyver show I tried it
and I was like this
I'm not feeling MacGyver here same thing
I'm like to change so much it's like
that Fantasy Island where they change it
from what it originally was something
fun fun and lighthearted and wholesome
to horror so I just don't get why so
many things get rebooted and when they
reboot they think the important thing is
make sure that you bring the costume
back or not even that sometimes it's
just the name it's like literally just
call him MacGyver and who cares if it's
like more violent or if it's more
cynical like that's a great thing about
the 80s it wasn't a cynical time really
you know to revert it right back to
videogames Resident Evil 2 the remake
captures what the first one is truly
about but it updates it to this you know
this can not contemporary with this
modern era it's I'm playing a resume
with
to now and I'm getting the same feelings
that I was when I played the first two
resident he was when Tom you know back
in the days but it's giving me more
insight and I think that when you do
remakes to things you're supposed to say
stay true to the source material but you
updated to a point where it is nostalgic
but it's also current so a lot of times
when they do stuff like that they lose
the nostalgic and just make it current
yeah I think it's like yeah I describe
it as losing the spirit of it yes the
soul the soul the soul drops how yeah
yeah you have to look at what is the
reason why the dynamic worked what made
except forget about just replicating
like like Marcy said replicating exactly
the costume in a suit that's gonna come
with it but what was the spirit of the
show what made it work and sometimes
they lose that and even the genre right
like you're sailing you just become
something completely different and a lot
of it just Hollywood sometimes with the
cash grab and you know I'm saying shout
out to my boy contrarian and he was like
you know Hollywood out of it ideas
sometimes and they just want to you know
pick something that work back in the day
and yeah throw a little Brandon wrench
exactly man so we're gonna move on so I
gotta ask the question that I asked all
the Lords of the room I need I already
know it cuz you did a video on it but I
want to see if anything changes I need
to know Lord Michael Mercy's top five
video games or franchises of all time
alright well I said earlier whenever you
make a decision you you end it with but
I could be wrong or it could be mistaken
so I don't really remember that five I
picked in that video okay let me let me
throw some games but whatever I say I
could be wrong cuz like in a year I
might feel different but start to rage -
whoa the rage - will always be on any
top five video game of all time list
could ever do amazing gameplay made
great music and I love the different
characters with a different movesets so
they weren't like identical
different looking characters he got max
with the Powerball err knuckle or was it
grand up I it was grand up ah yes let's
go
axel axel the only thing about part 2 I
missed was atom little brothers in it
that's why streets of rage remake is so
awesome because atoms in it
speaking on which again follow to tempo
that's the company that's handling the
streets a ride straight to rage for um
edition is officially gonna be licensed
by Sega Sega has given the okay
Adams in it man and it has a cell shaded
arch it looks phenomenal with the retro
and I told you use oh okay Cheryl he's
doing the music they've got the original
Streets of Rage 2 team in it it's gonna
be phenomenal but they're really paying
homage what Sega gives you the okay
that's a big deal so key but keep an eye
on that so continue salutely yeah
looking forward to Adams uppercut and
spin kick yes
kick a guy right up and scream with the
long long with that kick combo Metal
Gear Solid 1 for ps1 game changer
they're one of the best movies I've ever
seen and cool that I got to play that
movie yeah now I'm blanking on what was
on my list but yeah ii already sort of
to that you got you said like I said the
streets array that was all you list
she's raised to okay
you got the Metal Gear Solid 1 now you
had um for Super NES you had that uh
strong super Star Wars I think I said
Empire yes was it yeah yeah absolutely
yeah super Empire Strikes Back I love
the first one and then the second one
was just more better better graphics
more stuff to do the force powers was
ahead you can block with the lightsaber
now like in the movie flying the Falcon
man that as a vintage Star Wars fan
that's a dream come true and then super
Return of the Jedi was great too but I
felt like it was more of staying level
yeah that then going up like Empire did
and then what did I have for number four
for number four
you had lately had Zelda but yeah you
had he's gonna do that one you had a
part - yeah I was gonna yeah I was just
gonna say that Legend of Zelda to link
to the past
I didn't have Zelda one I started with
Zelda two so that was my intro to the
world of Zelda and that was mind blowing
being able to walk on a map and then
warp into the side scroller and then in
addition to that you've got a quest you
can go into towns and talk to people yes
that game like the year it came out was
mind-blowing cuz video games before
Legend of Zelda for me you either ran
and jumped yes or or there was like a
little bit of strategy type stuff but it
wasn't like a blend of three or four
different games yes that's a good point
and the cartridge was gold okay you
could save so let's just say state took
back that one absolutely now the last
what did you had this would hit me
because this was one of my favorite
arcade games outside of shinobi and I've
never heard anyone say this game so when
you had this up soft could attest for
all you WWF fans wrestle fest yeah you
know what I can I can tell you my list
today is the same as when I did that
video and it might change I could be
wrong
I could be I could have a different
opinion
wrestle fest was the game I could play a
half hour on one quarter so we had a
grocery store my town it's called
Kitchener it's in southern Ontario and
and they would do certain things like we
want to have the biggest grocery store
in all of Canada it'd have been all of
North America before that we had the
longest bar in all of the world if not
like at least North America it was a
place called Lulu's a great place for
music
but it was this ridiculous like giant
bar that went around the entire building
it was the size of a department store
like a Walmart I know a bar literally
just went around an entire Walmart sizes
store so then they built this grocery
store called Knob Hill Farms which was
the size it was insane it was for
Walmart's but a grocery store and they
had a rustle fest at the entrance so not
a quarter mom went grocery shopping and
I would be you know throwing guys out
over the top rope for the whole time
she's grocery shop doing that the Royal
Rumble or the or the tag team but I got
so good at that game it was the best
game I ever it was the only game I ever
really got good at at the arcade but
yeah every character in that game just
the most fun that music was so simple
but so good there's like a spiritual
successor slash sequel coming out this
year apparently it's called it's called
retro mania I saw I saw this months ago
almost so it seems I don't know if
they're gonna have their actual names
but that the so far two of the
characters are seen at both world wars
right so it's called retro mania it's I
believe it includes it's by some of the
people who made the original um but yeah
because we know a did you ever it was in
2012 they had like a an iOS version of
in the added stuff - it was pretty
what's iOS so yeah I want to play it on
my TV on a day later so this this is
apparently coming to all all platforms
this year who is it official or a fan
made oh it's official
I mean it's it's is a WWE I don't know
it's it's called retro mania so it's not
gonna have more
the licensure like the king like warrior
mr. perfect or anything well don't have
the likeness is more than likely but
they'll have to let me see them what am
I looking up well there are some people
that have the actual names you have the
blue meanie so animal and Hawk are there
as the road warriors see Nick Aldous
Tommy Dreamer Col Cabana NWA yeah this
is one of those things words it's
bringing that style of gameplay back
though which to me is missing I miss it
I've never been able to get into the the
modern wrestling games Smackdown vs. raw
and all that just looks too real to me
and I miss Russell fast or fire pro
wrestling was fun - OH or animated
looking yes yeah I want like yeah the
last part I Pro came out only for PC um
and it's only been a couple of years old
now but it's it's crazy it is really you
can do anything in that game you can
create anything in that game any
character that you want and it's just
fun looking to the character creation
there and see what people have made
because it's literally the entire
history of wrestling is in that game I
remember playing a fire Pro for my IBM
computer it was a Pentium computer and I
had to shut all know it like the old
days a computer computer you had to shut
like the graphics down and the you know
the resolution down just to get it to
run no sound playing fire pro with no
sound no graphics like just barely run
slow but I loved it cuz you could make
like Bret Hart in it
extinct that was they hit me hard now
people don't realize prior to Russell
fest about this yeah that's right
again before wrestle fans people
remember members saw we had superstars
of wrestling first right that was the
first way now was kind of simplistic it
was very you know whatever but it was
like it was a cool start and Andre the
Giant was the champs in that way yeah I
[Laughter]
think to do one of those what do they
called they sell at Walmart of man in a
Turtles I hope they do rustle fest I
don't know if they could with the
licensing of all the individual
characters but well I think back then
you know when WWE was WWF before crazy
stuff the way Vince was selling the
properties it was different you know so
now a lot of these guys own their names
opposed you know Vince was owning he
owns them lock stock and barrel I think
nowadays you know kind of changed like
with the rock owning his stuff and a lot
of the wrestlers on in their name is a
lot of these licensing deals have
expired so it is so excited here's one
way they could go they could make a guy
in a like a yellow singlet with curly
hair and call him mr. flawless listen
for me is better gonna do a change
because I was such an Ultimate Warrior
fanboy and those are the only two games
he really appeared and then Russell fest
graphically took it to the next level
yeah I was just like oh let's go so it
was it was truly it was
an impact like when he hit the ropes and
you heard that does the splash gotta go
play that game on my emulator afterward
and the one thing I don't get is like in
this day and age with all this amazing
technology how can we not play wrestle
fest with each other over the Internet
well we gotta get about here but oh wow
tremendous tremendous video game system
history eighties nostalgia we could
literally have a three-hour show just
talk to you about the 80s all day Lord
by goober see where can define people
find you what do you have going on next
on your journey I'm around YouTube you
just search for Michal mercy and then
all the links to all my other stuff is
on the page there too but I want to
thank you guys for inviting me on here
thank you so much he's been awesome chat
with you guys you're all good brothers
really appreciate the love and what
you're doing here is awesome man keep
keep going
thanks it's awesome it's a blast happy
that we crossed paths and like I said we
will definitely be doing more stuff for
the future ophélie I gotta get all that
uh what's the toy guys talking yes
so I guys we gotta do one of those I
gotta get on that show I mean with the
stories I could talk about my
transformers that I had and the GI Joes
that I had listen you could talk about
the stuff that he had I could talk about
the stuff that I have thank you for that
i gasm 's because that room is fantastic
well I'm gonna I'm gonna unplug I don't
know what this is gonna do to your audio
microphone can we get that towards you
and unplug my power here so and I'm
gonna give you a quick little tour
oh you want to do that let's get it here
okay I can hear you guys
yeah you guys hear me yes yes yes we go
yay mmm okay we're doing good here um
Wow I need some light here let's start
with the Transformers just getting it so
this is the Transformers wall oh wow
let's go let's get it those are my
triple changes right always opt about
your optimises yes I'm doing this
completely blind here I can't see yes
there's a hot rod in the bottom every
yep yes sir okay on radio music yes warp
has the middle box well if you can yeah
blaster with the tip yeah after the take
bag let's go Oh relax got indigestion
there I love the little mini bars
Powerglide oh the aerial box Omega
Supreme
oh you even had their own they made the
face of Earth
so yeah let's go let's go okay reticle
one I see jazz I see jazz okay
okay yes yes the legendary to me he was
the only black Autobot I don't care what
nobody say oh man these are all reissues
but they look just like originals Wow
Prince Adam let's get it
[Music]
King don't know about this oh this is
crazy
oh my god
[Music]
[Laughter]
that is insane unbelievable this John
Joe shouting Voltron let's go you left
the car 115 cars and trucks yet the 15
cars go to black line right there shout
out this finger he says do you have de
star ski and Hutch I know okay no that's
okay no not yet now yes soon you know
was the knockoff transformers you got
the gobots remember to go back no I may
go that's the only one he used to wreck
my boy devastate hang on front he's
directly I've seen it oh let's go that's
all mom Predacons and we don't know
he'll be running his prime was my Dolph
Molly's your iron humanoids I'm not
gonna let it go sting gotta let me go
[Music]
Oh GI Joe let's get it okay my god this
is insane
oh okay I remember as the pieces yes
Wheeljack we're really good how's mommy
sunstreaker instove that's the one that
could fly tracks the one that could fly
remember that one yeah yes Wow sea spray
look at that jazz look at the
articulation little people yeah you got
the little ones that could go inside
that's crazy
we're all Galvatron let's go star
screaming here's a hit
you've got you got the matron hi having
a gorgeous back full scene with him with
the matrix on at the end we got a rise
Rodimus prom let's go let's go Wow whoa
let's go that's the power Master one
much money he has him as he's opening
the matrix oh that was a little one used
to rhyme all the time with it really yes
really yes Wow unbelievable these are
visionaries with the Holograms sounds
the pics of boot to us with Jack he said
yo it looks like he jacked toys and
things
this is unbelievable i'ma tell you right
now if toys come to life
[Laughter]
we've not gonna go past that
Constructicons form the most powerful
robot devastated we shall rule
let's go oh yes a white one right yes
you sort of wait that was on sky 5
here's a Decepticon for a little bit and
then he became a normal one
yes ah but go back the cops I forgot
about cops a people whole childhood in
his room he literally has your old
shower and hold on Rambo I think it is B
I'm looking it up yo please I hope
that's not true Kobe Bryant that's what
I'll be so be room were just here in
here they sent TMZ reported killed in a
helicopter crash oh please I hope that's
not true no shout - Victor Alex team the
- our super shot damn it is a museum
amazing look at these judge Russ
oh man the logo shocked about Boy
Italian clowns he will love this right
here this is insane
there's a real life right now wow that's
crazy
unbelievable mask there's a mask you're
oh I see excellent we gotta get it for
disco squawks did it fly that's right no
color choose complete assumable but we
gotta get to the x-men over there right
quick question do you have any barrel of
planets I know
oh that will be easy that's my heart
yeah don't you do that you do that
battle-ax parents with my man marking or
man a g4 screw oh yeah
robo beers that's crazy
this is insane and the USS Flagg Wow
mercy this is amazing
I don't even know what to say this is
just unbelievable this collection that
you have a mask fire oh my god you know
[ __ ] he would do something like that
dude dude that was amazing thank you so
much oh my god Charlotte right there
that's literally our childhood it's
amazing
thanks for having me on that you have a
great day brother you know you welcome
back and around any time we will be
building up some more and again highlord
salute thank you so much for your time
brother and nerd thank you so much good
brothers awesome to meet you like chat
with you thanks so much everyone out
there for listening much appreciated
I don't know how to sign off here we go
I got it guys thank you so much
unbelievable shout out to my brother
that was crazy he took me back I don't
Atticus like screamy what is going on
it's all ties oh god damn it so we get a
new fight yeah the horrible news of Kobe
Bryant this is terrible terrible
he's too young to great Wow sad sad yeah
a horrible job who Kobe Bryant's family
oh that's very very very sad news
obviously sucks that it broke while we
were alive ik said we're getting the
details as it comes in so it looks like
five people were killed in a helicopter
crash of a Calabasas they shout out to
your hands out for that and
unfortunately our brother Kobe is gone
and it's sad and again condolences to
the family tremendous basketball player
closest thing the Michael Jordan we've
ever seen and he is gonna be missed
I mean damn you know unfortunately this
made me think about some things on
Twitter um over the week I just wanted
to say I give a shout out to Lord hazard
or my personal my personal and private
uh he told me all the time but I um went
through a difficult situation in this
past week with some co-workers and
thankfully he came out ok but um
unfortunately uh he survived the tragedy
so um just shout out to him and hope
he's uh on the road to recovery
absolutely and also shoutout to again we
put it in LA so I hope he we put it
again this one North Italian clowns you
know hopefully he's watching her get a
chance to see the toys from rest stuff
to give him some spirit but um obviously
we know his wife is going through this a
very horrific accident and she's on the
rebound she's on the mend but it's a
little complicated social ooh - all the
Run will put the GoFundMe and all that
stuff in the chat as well but on band
also thoughts and wishes go out - yeah
35 seconds um brother we are with you
Wow it's a tough one this is tough we
gonna try to get through the show um get
some spirits up cuz it's a rough one we
had such a hide in this weight so low
mmm but we gonna switch off with a shot
get some positivity to y'all on the pole
is up the winner of the three-way ILP
poll the last people actually just get
to the question first the poll results
are in and the people are spoken to the
question with the rumors of horizon zero
dawn coming to PC this year do you think
this will eventually open up the door
for the Sony first party exclusives to
launch day
date on PC the winner of the three-way
ILP poll dominating 82 percent of the
vote was yes the writing is on the wall
Sony wants the profit like any other
smart business group coming in that
second place and only 11% of the vote
was this will never happen so it's hard
exclusive only release after group and
in last place and only 5% but I don't
care it's all fun and games until it's
my favorite PlayStation exclusive group
so shout out to all the lords who
participated Lord addict what do you
think about this this was last week
people get a chance to to gauge your
feedback if you're still with us after
all that 80's talk did you got the end
dealer got a good you got a good people
have spoken
they said that it's only a matter of
time before PlayStation exclusives go
date date oh no you know piers now well
then they're the ones that's actually uh
you know paying attention what's going
on it's like I said when you know deaths
training was rumored to go like all
these games that's go into epic games
store going to steam Sony owns them all
Sony don't have to let none of this
stuff so like it's just a matter of time
they own all that stuff the what's that
that game the movie interactive game
they had Detroit yes they own that they
own that the other game that was made
for the epic game store like they owned
them they don't have to let them go
so it's it's it's ironic you go all
these years without them letting no
games of theirs go to PC and before you
know it they start letting all of them
go I think sooner or later you're gonna
see all you don't see Dane day you know
people don't think that that can't
happen but yeah I guarantee within three
or four years it's gonna be done today
I just want to get that super Chesire
before
we got a $5 super chat from I ain't even
tryna butcher that's whatever IOP crew I
just wanted to thank you for what you do
I we appreciate that man so we're trying
to keep bringing you different guests
with different tastes with your feel to
it because let me tell you something if
it didn't resonate with some of you I'm
pretty sure it resonated with a ton of
you yes you know he's a collector just
like you
I mean it's inside of everyone so you
know what what you take from that is you
you don't give up on your passions you
see his passion did you feel it because
I felt like living life to the full with
his life that's what's so get into it
talk about these SSD war speed versus it
already speed versus power and some say
speed kills
we gonna get to the room it's been like
going on in these rumor streets
so our first the new details about
microsoft next-gen SSD has found its way
online and according to some time when
there was a digi time excuse me they
reported that the series actually be
powered by a fire zone controller and
this is a PCIe 4.0 variant and according
to a freshly surface LinkedIn job
description which is an ex finds on
engineer he talked about that they will
be indeed using this controller for the
Xbox Scarlett so again and really four
generation SSD I'm currently using this
thing right now it is super fast but
however they talking about that on other
news of comes our boy Jeff Gordon from
windows central he's saying that the xx
the Xbox SSD could be half as fast as
the PlayStation 5 due to the nvme
interface in a stack could
surely all so devs are being told that
the series access up to two gigabytes of
Rhys B's but the PS 5 may well be faster
you know saying so we got that aspect
and then the last aspect I want to talk
about was that you know obviously more
journey when these guys were talking
about the PS 5 revealed additionally in
the white article they had mentioned
about how their SSD center is gonna be
different from anyone elses and they
talked about it's gonna be a higher
bandwidth and faster than anything
available in any PC now we still don't
know for sure you know the details
whether or not it's gonna utilize that
latest PCIe 4.0 standard but all intents
and purposes people think that the
playstation 5 one will actually utilize
that full potential of that controller
so I'm gonna bring this back to the Lord
you know I'm saying this is a hot topic
right now as far as that and again if
the rumors are true there's a lot of
rumors here right we still don't know
playstation factors not officially
revealed anything we still don't know
but I want to know you know is this
something that we should be concerned
about because you know obviously it'll
be faster and then we do know the Xbox
one series X has to allegedly has the
teraflop advantage or is it a situation
where this is the critical mistake
where's ddr5 for ps4 versus yes right
here is PlayStation Babel or at the mint
64 graphics quicker though they already
start with a sled there he's awake now
he's awake so I gotta get the software I
guess I got curious being something
editorial like it's just if it's true
it's this the Achilles heel this is this
we're soon is X wet cheap and it's only
my pouch on them honestly I don't think
so honestly you can tell you this is not
this type of talk about the the the
specific little details of each system
doesn't excite me as much like if you
want to speculate when we were
speculating about what type of CPU GPU
stuff that's interesting to me because
it gives you a general broad idea of
what
the machine can do right yes these stuff
that Sony showed initially with
spider-man is is super interesting and I
think the that's why I love consoles
right you can only get a situation where
an SSD can be this fast in a bespoke
piece of hardware like this because no
PC could do that because the problem
with the PC is that it's it's it brute
forces everything right everything is
just piecemeal and it's not it's not
built to work in conjunction with one
another so this is fantastic across the
board but until I see both of these SSDs
in in in wild really doing what they
claim they're gonna be doing and I'm not
really thinking I'm not giving it too
much credence either way because I'm
gonna tell you right now okay it was
cool that you showed me spider-man a
game that was built for the ps4 and
loading up in a couple of seconds now
it's only the next spider-man bigger
open-world crazier AI more detail in the
world everything told me that loading up
the st. the world the same way but on
the Microsoft side show me the new fable
hey you could see across the landscape
and nothing loads in and if you show me
that stuff in practice and it's doing
what it claims to be doing call me
impressed until there I don't care you
have to face 23 BK and why would the
father so he said it's probably true Mac
I'll talk about the SSD Sony
demonstrated the SSD he's saying the
books on the neck and they stem instated
the SSD on a ps4 game show me that same
level of speed and everything else they
cling on um game built for the PS 5 and
call me impressed same what Xbox code
your logo shut up Jim what Xbox don't
show me you know show me halo 1 running
in 120 frames per second I won't be
impressed
let's get the kid I heard him grunting
and groaning during my descriptions of
your own company don't believe it was
those factoids that you're trying to
push through these pipes your own
company took that fastest thing off the
board soon as they put it up there they
know it ain't true they sell fools so
you said that you talking all this hot
oh we're fast cuz we got a nice SSD what
about your CPU and your GP cuz you got a
fast Honda don't make you nice bra baby
remember kid in fairness we are alleging
we don't have the full no we don't know
hunt to be fair he's a hundred percent
right I eat the one that took that off a
website throughout this whole generation
was Sony cocky they don't come back in
like oh let's remove that words the
chalk where's the White House we gotta
take this off dance moves know they're
putting all the paperwork together with
crowns shock so they could just take
that spit just get a little bit off like
this all right
the fascist is showing you their logo
all I'm saying is we are speculating
that the Xbox Series X is 12 teraflops
we do not officially know that they're
nine we just speculate based on
something they're lying
so why why can't this rumor be true is
not true because when the boy posted it
so nice Magnus in and took it off the
power
Oh in Saudi themselves no they not the
fastest who is you to tell them they the
fastest the flash shout out to face 20k
and why my man you know what i'ma say
this right they got the fastest one
terabit SSD in the streets because if
you don't want to run with that
narrative then again when they user
interface went up they only have one
tera bit of info of storage on a joint
they're gonna be the fastest to this
desert fill up the storage Drive listen
when when Xbox jumps out with the two
terabit joint and y'all gonna be like oh
but we faster you have less terabits
let's teraflops well why you keep
talking about the lessor and they keep
talking about the price point gonna be
more your coming in would be lesser but
you're gonna be more dough price-wise I
mean I don't know they say D the fastest
and they pull it off the website
imma go with what was pulled this was an
efficient LinkedIn post for what was
leaked on what the Xbox series X it was
officially posted on a site and they
officially took it down okay so if Sony
them sell we who like wholewheat is
speculate when Sony definitively went up
there and took it down yourself worried
about them being the fastest that's
right they said we the fastest somebody
inside the corporate room said yeah we
we the fastest and somebody came and
wiped it off the boy you know how when
you inside the classroom but the
teaching out there and you write stuff
on the board and then the teacher come
in and looks at you with that face like
who put this crap they had that janitor
they asked him to put he just say he
just overheard it when he was mopping
the floors I thought it was which I was
y'all would've roll with that twelve
verses down
that's what was not is efficient I heard
we would be saying that 12 versus night
it doesn't look that well with if so if
Microsoft put some kind of job listen it
took a damn but they didn't David Gary
the five dollars which at we should be
concerned if it's true but it might just
be PS fanboy jealousy about the CPU GPU
in the Xbox X being better it's not a
whole shot the pixel bit G that's the
Holy Xbox website right now for series X
says the fastest most powerful eyeballs
right now it doesn't say console we ever
made hmm who did that boy listen I want
y'all to all put them field ominous
Maximus fences I'll put those up right
there because let me tell you this I
want to see some twelves are bigger than
eyes his arms is outstretched who put
them arms outstretched for you who is
out here sleep every time these dudes do
some fuel don't come and put the boot
upon 10 neck to boot upon the neck and
if you look at it right if you look at
the chip if they 8k on a chip
so chip that dose what are you chips a
Sony and it don't say faster so they put
that chip in that car key that's just
going on here
anyway axis facts you know King I was
watching something you got doing real
quick for me you gotta do that they got
a new car anyway it's a lot of questions
here we don't we all know official
obviously mad speculation this is all
fun speculation no one knows anything
but look my only concerns only know for
the piece
who are saying that you know it shoot it
hit there's some low holes we could poke
in a sense that the engineer in the
software who's leaking this for Scarlett
you know he denotes that it's for
Scarlett but Ramona as we know Scarlett
is to devices because he said hey don't
you say nothing he told everything no a
serial number can be confusing to people
that is goes inside he's fired as well
and he's got up there anyway all I was
saying is that he does say project
Scarlett is the family of the you know
on what the official ps5 details because
we can sit there say it fast or whatever
until Sony shows us this SSD solution
this proprietary solution and we have
real-world testing there is no way we
can definitively say anything we can't
say anything but the logo that's the
only thing we say right now we can't
tell you for fact we can't tell you any
but you know one King at least at least
they worked hard on that we know that
Microsoft likes to customize every
we don't know is what customers behind
[Laughter]
you one day you are onto something but
yeah that's the last thing I got said it
then the last to end effect even if
everything is true even if this is the
storage solution that is faster and
whatever people got understand when you
go from mechanical drive to SSD that
jump is tremendous so I said video he
said yes at the end of the day
everyone's playing games faster so even
if there is true we don't know this
could be minuscule differences and then
the other thing is if again the rumors
with 12 versus 9 is also true then that
means the GPU of the series X and all
that it's fast to terrify performance so
they could get more out of it still with
that existing solution that is still
crazy fast still a lot of speculation
just you know fun to talk about
dutchy love how colatina likes playing
the middle ground
[Music]
disclaimer that's beautiful see they
know he didn't know the fact I'm a cat
I'm a cap all day it's all funny Denine
what's bigger than 12:00 at 9:00 we
gotta pause a little bit to go to the
website you notice a most powerful and
fastest so right now you don't go out
with those bold claims without knowing
something thank you
but wouldn't you do you take it off the
website act like it never happened
when you don't know something and you
put it up you gotta take it down do
these last two Lord King out in a
certain region the Land of the Rising
Sun you sat there and laughed at me when
I told you my man said you know what we
have a deficiency in bits Department I'm
gonna go out there and pay the weight so
he went on this magical jet and he flew
out champagne and you know they brought
up a little real estate up there little
office view with a view his view and in
his sights he had the Land of the Rising
Sun oh and you don't think it boils him
every day how can he conquer this place
it started with a three prong approach
shout out to the man the myth the legend
mr. bill still willow and it all starts
with that key figure there at X cloud
because he saw every person in the land
that arises son as a cellphone how can I
get my tech into these people's hands
without them knowing it so he studied
the way of the ninja while he's out
there and he's doing that one was he you
can't slay a dragon just by grabbing him
by his tail see you gotta make sure that
you had the magic knife so how do you
cut the Dragon Scale you make sure that
you got a developer that gets straight
to the call you may have felt Dominus
maximus Spencer out there talking to the
developers this show
X Club and talking about game Pass and
you know while he's dead he said check
out our new system and lo and behold our
fearless leader has reported back has
said there's wonderful talks going on oh
elephant's I love you what we're showing
and unannounced and announced games and
the key word is unannounced games are
looking fantastic my question to the
realm is is filled out man is Maximus
Spencer or something win-win no other
Xbox executive has feel like you're
reaching on this to something in Japan
with the whole the x-files the mobile
gaming any chance to I mean I feel like
that's a better concept maybe if it was
done ten years ago but I felt like the
damage has already been done the switch
if people were buying a handheld nine
times I didn't they're buying a switch
up there or down there I don't exactly
know where they're they're located for
from currently where I'm at but you know
I hope so that they can do better I do
think X clouds gonna help them in a lot
of markets that they don't have
apparently but I don't think it's gonna
be like a drastic huge improvement whoa
so you do feel they should you he's you
just stay out the region just just like
you ought you have to try mm-hmm that's
one of the reasons that they're they're
hurting so much there right now because
people stopped trying mm-hmm
shout out to Jonathan B to file out a
super sad I heard Phil say forget it
I'll take it all in a quiet Japan or
hash tag or got it
[Laughter]
you know they're being one of the
biggest things that Microsoft's doing is
their libraries just more diverse now
you know it might actually be more
beneficial to Japanese gamers because
they have more stuff they want to play
up and so now we for the most part we
just had shooters that's all mmm a lot
of Japan okay I do think that they need
to buy a couple Studios you know around
that type of the world before people are
really gonna start going out and
supporting that brand what about about
this though like we have to we have to
say this in in reference to feel like at
least I would see in terms of game pass
his acquisition of more Japanese titles
towards on gamepad you see that your
cool just stuff come in you know do you
feel that that may point towards like
him really trying to you don't kind of
just put his beat down as far as getting
roots down and making sure that those
titles that normally during the 360 air
or whatever like those were missed for
the most part those are always mezzo max
I think for the most part the reason
he's trying to get these games is
because not necessarily he's trying to
get him to win that audience he's trying
to get him to make sure that you know up
until now personas been exclusive
Jacques has been exclusive like it's
best I had those on your platform that
might help you in that region then to
not have those platform in the
competition they pretty much have padded
exclusives they don't really it's not
exclusive it's just that the the
platform eight never really tried to get
those games so now right right and even
with the Final Fantasy right they need
to get all those people thought that
wouldn't happen in the Kingdom Hearts I
believe the older ones wanted to I never
thought those games come over to the
same this is why I found the baffling
that you're just doing this and you're
saying this because he did this for you
Oh like like and I said relief is
astounding me because he did this for
you like you
thought it would never happen and he
just turned around and made you a
believer but yet you still give this to
a point it comes to a point where you
just believe in him to a point no after
a certain amount of years of those Sega
games not being on sure I'm sure there
is a demographic of people on Xbox that
likes those games that's one of the
reasons Kingdom Hearts 3 didn't sell
fantastic on Xbox because we literally
never seen a Kingdom Hearts on the
platform but my question to you is this
right cuz you're saying that your level
of belief in the man he wasn't in
control before he's in control now so
whatever those dudes did before he's
correcting their mistakes this man has
actually been walking on water and
you're looking at him like he's not
turning water into wine and his fan I
don't believe you're Jonathan beers or
addict neck baffling ungrateful
he's like fraud alert you cool over and
won't you do me a favour of their king
once you go look up the key of Hearts 3
reminded what you go tell me the Xbox
release date in the place you tell me
you know it you tell me that PlayStation
1 just came out we don't get the Xbox
one till like next month or the ok so we
get it next month in the past we never
got it so that's my way but this is it
you need to tell me at the end of the
day it's not like this is a game that
was that was funded by Saudi this is
literally a Kingdom Hearts expansion
that the Xbox demographic have to wait
up until a month to play but do we know
about the what do we know about the
marketing rights do we know about any
type of exclusive deals and why was it
key to march 3 I'm just asking I'm
saying it seems to be has to be some
form of a reason as to why put it this
way do you think that Microsoft wouldn't
want it day and date the same time as
Sony I mean they're very fulfilling
I feel like with
it only being a month what part of me
feels like it was developed first for
the PlayStation and therein it's still
under certifications and stuff to come
out for the Xbox so you're saying that
it's not Phil's fault but Phil is
getting it there well it's not why is it
coming for years
Dalek goes oh you're a month late like
you've never got cheese on your burger
before but now you're getting cheese
they say yo you gonna get cheese later
this game
Phil just said you know what I got king
of pocket let me work on that at the end
of the day I get a whole month
mine are you sure it should still come
out but if it's not coming out day date
by the time the actual DLC largers on
the Xbox people that got multiple
consoles has already picked it up on
PlayStation people's already ruined it
from looking up YouTube videos like it's
ridiculous that the DLC doesn't come out
on the platform when the actual game
came out why is there a month but we
both why is there muck between my
question to you is do you think honestly
it's because Phil is not on the ball or
not trying to get it on day and date as
the PlayStation I don't know what's
going on because they don't get that
information out all I could say is I can
only tell you what's the facts the facts
is that it's on one platform a month
before it's on the other and the actual
game came out day indefinitely so
because of that this doesn't interest
you then that it's even on Xbox because
you want it at the same time why I
already looked it up on YouTube because
I'm not waiting a month for to know the
story and what happened you know sure
it's cool that you know we are giving
these games but let's not
let's not act like that he doesn't have
a long way to go with absolutely shadow
shadow JD gigging finest in which I xbox
tried the early years of 360 which
resulted in more than 1.3 million
consoles over Japan but Sten stopped
supporting them hashtag do it again and
better and then yes Thomas Franks we do
know shelter 2000
Kobe Bryant did pass away thing did you
did you get the other day game of the
foundry and oh yeah I got victor with
the harada-san ii I got the victim but
you got to get the JT game buff above
that okay shouts a date again with the
500 super chat digital phones we already
dealt with this the i/o this is our past
this is the last topic the i/o on the
Xbox series xx 40 times faster than
current gen Xbox 1 X and the PCI Express
4.0 standard is capable of more than 2
times faster than this 40 times because
I know I watched somebody video and I
was confused because I watched so many
videos while I'm falling asleep so I
know somebody was saying that the Xbox
one is the fact that he was able to go
over to Japan and get those Yahoo's a
game on game on game pass no less not
even just bringing them for bringing
them to the service so that those who
have not had an opportunity to try them
don't have to go out there and purchase
them piecemeal they're gonna be in-game
pass I think the relationships that he's
fostering over there are continuously
getting better and better
I agree 100% with King they do not the
only way Xbox is really gonna sell is
gonna be successful in any way shape or
form over there is X cloud and if you if
you can get Japanese developers in
Pocket on the Microsoft side to make
stuff exclusively for Microsoft that is
very Japanese right and
and then you push X cloud over there I
think at least from that point
perspective you can have some success
over there and never gonna want a box
that comes from America with this
especially it could be they don't even
want their own box it's like they don't
even want placed the switch is
playstation in the face over there
because they just don't want boxes under
under the TV anymore everything it's
portable everything's mobile over there
so you need to add rel an open space
like what you do well they don't have my
face yet which is why this their society
has just gradually sort of shifted
towards more being interested in
portable stuff so I don't think I think
X cloud is really the only way they push
the Xbox brand over there now what he's
doing it is also what King says like
you're doing if attic you're doing it
for those gamers over here that love
those Japanese games they have not had
it on this platform they need to bring
it they need to bring those games day in
day Neil needs to come out day in day on
the next month yes work towards that
right um well that ever happened I don't
know but I know he's working towards
that I think it's important because when
you talk about people who have the
ability to have both you give them a
decision to have to make right if it's
coming out on one a year ahead of time
or not at all on the other one there's
no decision to make so let me jump in
real quick um yeah listen I he's coming
from you know I'm saying I'm gonna say
his frustration with certain things but
I'm leaning towards what king of saying
this instead look at the end of the day
when you haven't had success in an area
right and it's something that's been
overwhelmingly not positive in past
generations you know you have to still
try different approaches to skin the cat
so to speak right so we know like you
said the traditional console solve it's
not gonna fly you know I'm saying that's
just not the way the culture is over
there and like alex says as far as the
smaller spaces the living spaces you
know mobile is really huge over there
but they didn't ii mean i don't want to
get gas
but I will say that what has given me
hope shout to stinger in the chat he
said it it seems with Phil which is
different from even the pita more and
all the other execs they seem to always
like in respect and they seem amicable
to work with him right that that is
something I feel different and the
reason why I got excited is because I
don't know if I saw that tweet that Phil
is talking about the Kings talking about
with Phil when he said hey we went over
there you know we had this good arm back
from Japan into the team talking and
listening to the amazing studios and
publishers about 2020 and beyond really
strong energy and excitement about
gaming future in Japan then immediately
after he tweets that this to me was
significant this is my man when when
when Harada from Tekken responds to you
and says yes thank you for your time and
have a good time as if y'all been in
discussion about something like like
Yahoo Circle is in game path we know how
Tekken was in game path we know how
Tekken um debuted on the Microsoft stage
that evening you know saying so again
it's these little things and remember he
was at fan fest gasps Simon
the posters and stuff like this is his
little things that these people aren't
seeing it's like what you call it king
is like you know you shaking a hand
you're kissing the babies you got to do
the groundwork but your first like Phil
is not just throwing money at it he's
doing the groundwork now as far as this
Mario I would love for them to purchase
to do how realistic I don't know but I
feel and King me you talked about this
the approach they need to do is we do
know they're setting up there they set
up shop out there right mm-hmm
and my thing is get a young team that is
like homegrown from the area so we get
fresh blood that is a Japanese Xbox
exclusive studios you don't saying how
great if you come back the money truck
up to Namco or from great and they
accept it that would be metal but hey
you might have to start small you know
I'm saying so this way you get people
from the culture you nurture my thing is
revisit old franchises that debuted on
your system with Miss Walker right hand
blue dragon and stuff like that go right
back to these old
franchises that starter on your platform
that had made a home man
that has a base yeah yes he was just as
good as final fan right absolutely
for attic this is this is this is why I
was more hopeful to be honest with you
right because attic is more of a
Japanese gamer now all right you can ask
cog you know every year of like mist
walkers here beside you it was one of
the odd the e3 we would see he was in
the crowd like he was a crowd he's got
to be announcing something and then hmm
another year with Iowa mr. Walker doing
mobile game from Jonathan B I heard Phil
just tweeted that it can catch these
hands have tagged Lord Judas the first
the one before that day to gamer shy not
the date again with the $5 super chat
what did the rumor of Lockhart being a
for teraflop hand held true that would
be a classic field ominous move come be
my friend and slice there's a lot of
rules no no a lot I don't know what to
believe right now you know all I would
say like I said you got to start
somewhere
I'm saying you got to start what I call
it's like the street team you gotta hit
the streets you don't say you gotta put
your fliers out you just can't throw
money on it and walk away right and I
feel that's what Xbox is used to do
throw money at it
walk away no you got that cooperation
with the disrespect right so what I
would say is a shout out to um the
beginning of the process is what he's
doing he's going out there because you
know a lot of the biggest reasons that
you know Konami people who are not
Konami they don't really make aims but
you know a lot of these Japanese
developers and publishers don't release
games on xbox is because they don't sell
that great but at the end of the day
like until
someone starts making sure these games
come here and taking that initial loss
from the start and making sure that he
is a loss anymore word game past at it
mm-hmm these games coming on game pass
well did we get the final fantasy we're
coming in 2020 all right listen for you
I understand that does not interest you
right but you gotta understand there is
a huge base of Xbox players no I can't
wait for those guys that's gonna be I'm
talking about before the Final Fantasy
started hitting the the platform like
you know like I said this Kingdom Hearts
3 it's not come the the remake things
not coming out for a month yeah you know
once you cease games start coming out
they some of them might not sell well
the first because they're still a vast
majority of games that has it came to
Xbox that's in that that citrus peel and
so these games start you know being
honing along this platform they're not
gonna sell more because they don't come
here there's a reason we don't get the
person B's not letting go he said Phil
put that I'll pee on his back for attic
and this is the tank see kids 2020 right
now he's not laying though he's like you
you are soul Lord Judas to Lando
eighty-six to the five dollars with the
chat let's walk it would be green that's
not having like having MJ on your team
Sakaguchi's they got this man said 2020
like it's five years locker is the
surface phone at it come on I gotta
leave a Colonia come on addict to the
bushes we go stop is an abuse he just
came back from sit is he's still on his
medication side man I do understand what
he said you know say I get it you know
for him you know for someone who has
these series he's like yo a month later
with the DLC and three months later when
the other do
got it right now it's still not enough
you know for him and all we're saying is
just like a fellas working the fact that
it's even on there is a positive the
fact that he's got that presence there
is huge and the last thing I wanna say I
was one gwg trying to grow women gaming
podcast I was only yesterday salute them
another round um we were talking about
it and the King's point about leveraging
X cloud you know I'm saying and and
utilizing that tech to be on those
mobile devices and also you know I'm
saying just to get maybe I can say that
Japanese studio involvement by its
proper name oh boy I gotta see when it
comes to you know the next Final Fantasy
and I'm you look Final Fantasy 7 remake
that's not coming to Xbox for a year you
know let's see if the next Yakuza comes
out for Xbox day a day because I'm not
convinced that will at the end of the
day like it's like timed exclusives I've
said from the start they are important
by the time a platform gets these games
it's not gonna necessarily you're
completely right from the casual
standpoint right because the casuals
they'll see marketing right they'll see
Final Fantasy and I'll see on
PlayStation you'll see you know the
logos we've had six remakes of this game
come out before it actually finally at
Xbox who did that for you listen we're
gonna have to stop sitting here acting
like this man you know what he did like
he hasn't you know him actively putting
a mountain on his back and crossing it
across the street for you and you
sitting there saying like that feat
isn't worthy of his praise it really
means nothing to me shows up you know
what choice you're gonna go out there
with the wash eyes because you're gonna
be playing it with the burnt eyes
played on play away what he told you is
you could wait a month and play with the
superior graphics you can go over there
with the dynamic resolution and have
words all the Dragon Quest games King
well when you got to get the cataract
fixtures this is what happens you go
over there you play over there you gonna
have to fix the cataracts later yes we
doing the checkerboard oh my god so what
do you want you you matter feel cuz he's
saving your eyeballs you miss your
eyeballs up addict Phil left his family
to go to Japan for you and he sat there
at the airport now he'll be back
sometime next year I love you guys he's
mad right now he slammed this coffee
right now because he's listening to the
podcast Lord I do not represent the
whole actually plays final fantasy said
come on now which one every big stop
here's a prime example go back and watch
the reaction that we had at the video
game awards and the first thing you hear
kognito say oh they don't
he thought they're about to announce the
7 remake he started getting it in his
bag and then they didn't and he's like
that's a mistake that's gonna call it
how we gonna call it but the difference
is when I see someone putting the effort
to try to get things to turn around
that's different
and again rome is not built in a day
they're like you gotta take what you
could take so yes do does it hurt that
it's not day and date when they have
there's absolutely but the fact that
but you disgust me when you see a
situation like Street Fighter or certain
games that were on PlayStation and they
like y'all this is never coming to Xbox
mm-hm that hurts so there are some in
the xbox basis saying look alright
y'all got it I'm cool I could wait I got
all this other stuff to do you know Sam
play and we'll get it when we get it and
some who say just like kids playing with
the cataract they'll say yo I'm gonna
get the best version of the game so I
wait with the better fidelity of what he
said I heard his toes birthday he said
nah yo Johnny B you got it man Swedish
Parvati before
Charlie be taking back he said is a
person we've said for years how many
years if we said we wanted some kind of
JRPG exclusive on xbox like how many
years of the generations would buy and
we saw ain't got one no he said this is
hilarious much love to the Lord hit the
damn like button if you have ever suffer
your Atticus back you know it's funny
$5 to purchase from JD game to stop this
Zoo is bring you Japan bit by bit
20 alone you will see more Japanese
games in the last 10 years
hashtag doing it it shadow game a
brother oh no he's not doing well please
send everybody's got that flu that's my
brother Jay Fonzarelli from the RDX
podcast oh he was supposed to be on
today he's supposed to be on today
during the retro section so Lou my bro
you know Sam but you know salute the
Attic for standing on his Square being
petty
that's all I'm saying people keep
reading the final fantasy covering the
game past thing they announced this and
2019 it was like it's covered at 2020
hey they acted like it was like the
beginning obviously we're at the end of
the first month but still like it would
have been warning
so disrespectfully you I don't know what
medicine they got you on remix I I
expect some final fantasies being played
by you when I just told you he knows
what Final Fantasy came out later at it
he knows where Final Fantasy came out
for that PlayStation I ran on I
purchased all right um play Final
Fantasy I played all the Final Fantasy
alright and in when it when it does hit
game pass more than likely I'm gonna
talk my son through it we're gonna go
play some Final Fantasy but I'm one
child to know the difference between
hope and no hope alright so cuz at this
point sound we got hope yes alright so
you have hope see when when you cool it
wasn't coming I didn't I said oh I don't
care about that but now I'm gonna hits
game pass let me say let me check it out
let me see what the fuss is about
because it wasn't a game that I was
gonna run out and spend $60 on or
whatever I didn't care for those two for
for the thug version of Shenmue that's
what I thought it was I thought it was
Dylan version of SHINee and I did not
want to be the drug-dealing cartel
running Shenmue you order bootleg a
grand theft auto I just didn't care for
it
so but it's in-game past I said well let
me let me get her the chance when it
shows up that's the power if these are
these things that I'm telling you if
he's over into this this beautiful
foreign land he has to sell his wares
enough to go over there wit with with
different wigs you can't go over there
with the same thing with this big goofy
box on the nasty controller that don't
fit in their hand
you have to go in with what a
switchblade our switch Army knife with
multiple tasks that you can show these
people that you bring something of worth
to they're oriented big country so he's
he brought of X cloud and we gotta stop
calling it X hub we're gonna call it the
stadia killer that it is isn't stadia
house stadium fed on arrival and expire
did therefore you who did that for you
who beat back the white Jon Snow himself
its Maximus his respect to stop playing
I he out here joking around and it's no
games the white Walker is dead he
doesn't kill quite well he had the
dragonglass his TZ said okay you know
what we can't put these traditional
systems in their house right and not
doing it they're buying they did their
purchasing Nintendo switch before for
the portability of it for the
space-saving aspect of it may not even
really buying Playstations like that out
there so how can I get this oh they have
cell phones I can do it the sneak wave
put the server's outside of Sony house I
could actually get this app on it a
phone don't cost nothing to put this app
on your phone and when you are in my
ecosystem is he's gonna infect them from
within
okay to a ride or the Saudi car bushes
you were to get JD gave us sounds a JD
game with the final asset which at IO
p.m. panel and chat how many Japanese to
do you think Microsoft is buying
building and / building and what Studios
do we do we how that they are acquiring
do we know that they're acquiring a
definite thing they got is trying to get
one for sure that one I don't I mean
it'd be great if they like that's what I
would do from the ground alright that
car they built one from the ground up
young talent Ontario heads was front
right doing it no no I
nobody this how he gonna get the old
heads the old heads you finish them with
game pass you get that upfront bread of
what could your joint could make when
it's over here
and I'm saying then come in pocket we
want the new dudes with the new fresh
ideas
let's get them wrong shouted Delilah HD
Google's acquired studio stores honestly
that scares me because if they acquire
studios that means exclusive to that
platform and I don't want to hear about
no title I want exclusive the stick yes
Lister to be honest that's just me you
know and I horrible death they're ready
dead on arrival no my mom purchase a
stuff they have to switch up their whole
model yeah the free version is supposed
to come out sometime this year that
needs to come
ASAP otherwise they get done that's why
I was so happy because I was scared that
it was locked in yeah facing a pro
consumer so apparently they have been in
a two-year battle with the Norwegian
consumer Council over what is there I
guess they're right over there because
it's not illegal over there right to
deny people refunds on any shop digital
purchases it was in the courts for two
years and just recently it was decided
that they were not in the wrong so they
can continue to not allow refunds for
pre-orders on digital purchases no
across the board because at first there
was something that I read that said well
if the game if you pre-ordered the game
and you downloaded it right and you
downloaded it but the game still wasn't
available but you were able to download
it early you're done you have to keep
that game
and so when you look at Nintendo's
policy its straight-up none like if you
preorder it and the game is a month away
no canceling that listen Nintendo has
never cared a rat's ass about you I
think I think more than even more than
PlayStation and Xbox because at all
they're all money-grubbing companies
right but you have to have you have to
have something forward facing that
brings in your customers right it's it's
the nature of the big corporation but
Nintendo has never shied away from being
very blatant about sheisty you over like
a what he'll come is that the you know
the merit the Mario image makes people
think oh then any other down right the
other scheisse just when it comes
milking you for money and this is a one
of my favorite this is one of the most
egregious examples of this um this is
not good you should be able to return
the game you have not yet played listen
you know it's pathetic about it is that
they're the only company that's doing
this yes even Saudi leave it like you
can cancel your pre-order you know say
it you can refund your each shop these
delicious grandpa bin finesse in a long
time
yes a think about grandpa he don't put
none of his games on sale he is hand
over fit he about his brain he like this
I got to this position I'm not changing
we go go to court and you're not gonna
get these refunds and that's how it's
going laughs a leg is all good and funny
that's the kool-aid a drink she gotta be
mine washed out you don't see how they
mine is washed out like had this been
somebody else they wouldn't be smiling
and joking aqui can they do this you'd
and then it come on be like it's a me
listen they not gonna stop me right now
so listen let me tell you something what
was
here right now is they deep perpetuating
this propaganda and pushing it right now
listen what y'all do right now is don't
preorder anything on Nintendo because
I'm gonna tell you right now they say
your money's in is locked
I'm not sure you build it your switch is
turned off and your kids can't get
inside because if a key go in there and
he preorder a whole bunch of games just
50 cents 50 cents 50 cent and you are in
for $2,000 yeah yo that's a good point
real now real talk
that is a good point you know me kids
don't like I used even Google there was
one time this little funny good start
there was a Transformers sauce Jeff
let's go nobody's there
chapter since their visitor chat there's
this transformer car game that your boy
was mad at your boy spike it was g1
transformers I spent like like a good
two hours Gabe I stupid so it went so
bad that Google contacted me and said
look we see these abnormal amount of
digital purchases or your account so
allow you to buzz back have you to be a
fraud alert or B I'm guilty as charged
Bailey so the fact that how scary is it
that if you're a parent of a switch
owner and yo kid go buck wild on the
eShop you're finished you're done and
you know and it knows that you should be
watching your kid
we don't give back any dough get the so
good but I kick you right we're gonna
let them go over this today I mean when
it comes to stuff like we already know
they listen they stick out we use for
fun and our shoutout from Nintendo
brand-new right now you cut that we you
500 cash listen I told you this is the
reason why I really don't mess with
those dudes and they've been beating me
since little you can go get a new brand
new Super Nintendo right now the $750
they don't have black Fridays they just
have Friday with the rumors of the PS 5
apparently having a faster SSD solution
in the series X do you think more
Hardware advantages will eventually be
revealed by Sony as we get closer to its
launch the choices are a yes B no Sony
is skin 12
teraflops is greater than 9 teraflops
well see I don't care as long as that
ETS RAM and connect we pray know is in
the bushes in the series X shout-out to
all those who participated gonna rock
the boat we will get that up there
iron Lord salute to rock gaming brother
my eighties brother Lord Michael mercy
who killed it today oh my god the
nostalgia it was just amazing we could
have talked to him living for three
hours the stories the collection he was
kind enough to give was gonna make me go
to Canada it was beautiful yes it's
tremendous man I mean we could just talk
for days a salute to him sort of the
Attic for coming back off the sickness
even though he's very disrespectful
filled dominus maximista he's on a Sony
medication we got
right we gotta get me remove that forgot
who did that for him his lungs his lungs
I do remember it again yes condolences
to Kobe Bryant I heard I'm here the
daughter too
very sick what his daughter - that's
what I'm here and I'm gonna I'm gonna
look more see if that's true
hold on shot to send in a chat scream in
a chair all the people no doubt but yo
saw let's get us out of here man we're
gonna file to find you what you got
going on I hope you on Twitter and
examine PSN Xbox Live I'm gonna work but
when I come back hopefully get a get get
a little bit of Star Wars in finally you
started that and yeah like I said before
man I got out and just just get better
Lord has a door Oh Lord clowns cat daddy
Lord bloody ducks just posted a spy
yeah about his aren't so condolences as
well I mean this is horrible guys so
just keep your chin up try to enjoy the
rescue something with your families mhm
appreciate appreciate who you have still
with us Lord King man it was good when
you go I know it's coming right now
check it out right there boy oh yeah
fine first of all you can find me on
twitter twitter twitter to catch me on
that tweeter beaten but yo yo check that
out see the kos what he's my tomates
Willie Manning that I had that comment
to know it is by far one of the best
scopes you own a character
I'm not even gonna front like it is
amazing yeah you showed the arm in the
dark joint or the lighter features right
right now it's on purple yeah it has a
CPU inside there um the main housing
told in that gyroscope beautiful best
thing that they got going on there and
the wondrous minds of the artists who
put this together this is probably one
studios and until I can get a better
spider-man that is my main spider-man um
this week we have a I had to do three
quick videos um oh not three quick video
but three videos because I hadn't got
these from eBay well not this one this
one came from a facebook friend and my
statue group so he had to go up out of
respect and then the other two that I
got is from eBay so I had to check those
out cuz you know anytime you purchase
from eBay don't trust them boy never do
so um those videos going up cog is a
ecstatic about the next video because
it's one of his villains this is a month
of spider-man so I'm giving you
spider-man four weeks of spider-man low
so you're going to get villains and also
you started off with the hero that's at
Kos also go to Lords of game and dinette
where we have new and exciting writers
law kognito pulses daily Wow when
Cognito talks about on his segment right
now at the end he'll tell you the new
writers that we have in I'm not privy to
say that stuff yet until he announces it
until the ink is dry then he announces
that stuff but um it is a beautiful
thing to see if you've never been to the
website it brought a tear to my eye
because most of the time I'm looking at
it through my phone when I got a chance
to look at it on my PC Oh to be a part
of something that beautiful in that epic
brought a tear to my eye
um also you know we've been thrown attic
and the bushes a shout out to and the
bushes and the tea
[ __ ] who did that for you did we have a
ton of catchphrases of ton of IP IOP is
the isms that's there and also you know
rep your Lord because you got Lord
kognito your Lord addict you got a lot
of sovereign but the four wash me out
the four horsemen is in there he's
rocking it right now also we're going to
packs guys let me let me let me I mean
let me say something that's so
monumental because of how I feel for the
community how I feel about the team how
I feel about everybody has been
collabing every last person that's going
to pax is media everything and I'm not
telling you we got one media past we had
to mediate know every last person that's
on a team we got a two-man team that's
going in that's consistent of three
people each so the house is full impacts
the team is full media that means no man
left behind every man walking in that
door is 100% media and that's done
through you guys to support the level of
dedication that you give us we give them
back to you and trust and believe you
hit that joint button you joined on us
we're going to give you so much content
that is going to you you're really gonna
understand the level of work that we're
bringing to you pax is our home and
we're going to go in there stomping the
yard it's gonna be a special one we
definitely looking forward to again
shout out to all the lords that are
there also you know got their media
badges the Loch Ness monster came and
got net just been tremendous the riders
have been phenomenal um definitely want
to salute the two new riders on board I
wish I might wake up video tech UK
tremendous Red Dead Redemption article
right now please check it out he had
he's killing these troops right now
super talented from the UK of course my
boy dog challenge from Croatia in the
building breaking down a technical
knowledge breaking down frame rates
there's a great article up right now
Nords a game of dinette and soon to be
the ink is dry buddies we would make
yes there but I soon to be hopefully you
know say I could say it cuz you know I
thought oh is the rage virus man race
virus is tremendous right now he has an
amazing piece on Ninja Theory so
everything that they're doing all the
new projects project Maura please man
again Lords a game of dotnet if died not
on it like listen it is moving the
support is crazy please keep sharing
those articles people treat knows or who
it really helps us and that's what we do
we get because of what you guys have
done for us we get a chance to be
meeting so yo Lords a game and dotnet
y'all y'all know what it do support
support the realm we are here we are
here launch a game with that neck check
us out and we will be at packs like that
Kingston we're gonna start this yard
we're gonna provide you our coverage as
yeah I've never seen before exclusive
members will get some actually exclusive
footage and stuff from the cutting room
floor some stuff that we left out that
will be exclusive to them so make sure
you remember you get the cool emojis you
already see they get to who done that
for use and all that fun stuff and yeah
that's pretty much all I got everybody
look enjoy your son that gets out to
Michael mercy we got some more fun
guests coming up or February's gonna be
huge or we got such big guests coming up
please stay in touch can you want to say
something for you know everybody look at
your Sunday I said our condolences to
the people that we lost today and again
everyone that you do have and it's
around you show some love and appreciate
them because life is short you already
know what it is so enjoy we oughtta be